well when the 2020 race started Joe
Biden looked like a very safe pick and
of course he was the consensus pick a
permanent Washington now it's not as
clear and Biden in some polls looks
strong in other ways he looks maybe
weaker than expected according to new
reports though the Biden campaign is
considering a new and bold strategy what
if Biden promised to serve only one term
if elected would that work or would it
serve only to emphasize his advanced age
Dana Priya hosts the daily briefing with
Dana Perino and she joins us tonight so
I mean so Joe Joe Biden is younger
actually than Bernie Sanders so for him
to say I'll serve only one term appears
to be conceding that maybe it's not a
good idea for someone this old to be
president I think it's super interesting
where it's all coming from as well so
Ryan Lizza of Politico got this scoop
and apparently there is a debate amongst
former Vice President Biden's top
advisors and some of these prominent
consultants and they're throwing this
out there right a little Chum in the
water to see what would people think
about this or a trial balloon might be
another way to put it and in one way it
emphasizes one of your weaknesses right
that's right but the president says
you're sleepy or too old you don't have
the energy you're not out there on the
cancer you can't fight for this country
the other hand there are some people who
say when Americans are saying they want
is an end to the chaos they just want to
pause for a moment right but I have a
few big problems with the idea of
running for president and saying you're
only going to run for one term one you
don't have any political muscle to get
anything through so you're just
basically going to pause for four years
you don't want to do anything else also
if you're the Democrats how do you
rebuild the Democratic National
Committee with a lame-duck president on
his first day and you will have a
primary that will continue to imagine a
five-year Democrat totally which is
actually me
the consultants would make so much money
no of course I'm not going to do that
but I do that is an issue and it also
makes him seem like he's not up for the
challenge of the job as if he needed as
Alex Castellanos was saying he needs to
come in calm everything down save the
country from going into crisis and just
be the stopgap measure until
Democratic Savior can emerge and it
would put huge emphasis in the vice
presidential pick because you know you'd
be buddy not just for the VP but in
effect for the nominee four years from
now right and also because you know
identity politics does play a role
especially in the Democratic Party right
so now they're going to like who would
be best there's somebody who actually
says maybe Stacey Abrams of Georgia of
course she's still like she won the
governor's election down there in
Georgia saying but would that be vibrant
enough but let's say that he's picked
Stacey Abrams immediately she thinks
she's the frontrunner to run in 2024 as
the Democratic nominee because why
wouldn't she think that but they would
be surrounded by people who want to take
her out yes so you've just explained in
about two-and-a-half minutes why this is
the worst idea anybody's ever come up
with maybe I don't know if ever but also
they just the thing is they throw this
stuff out there and Biden he still is
doing very well nationally in the polls
they're not amazing it is amazing you
got stop to start calling Teflon joe you
predicted for the beginning he will be
the nominee
and if I didn't wait did I predict
pointing words in you credit for
prescience because I guess the u.s. did
a pretty great to see you too thank you
thank you